[Music]
let's begin with the going public
question and just how you
thought about that and made decisions
around it
and then
from there into new products new revenue
streams things like that
okay so first of all the idea of going
public for example last time we talked
you know i don't know exactly what was
going on six years ago in my head but
the idea of public going public i think
around then
just seemed so foreign so like that's
never gonna happen
i wasn't just not thinking about that
once we figured out our revenue and we
figured out that we could make a lot of
revenue the first time this really was
discussed was we were having a meeting
with one of our board members his name
is bing gordon and his bing is like a
legendary guy in silicon valley very
famous very famous says a lot of crazy
stuff
a lot of really good crazy stuff but
also sometimes it's like just really
crazy stuff
and you know he was just sitting there
and we were talking about our revenue
and he said look
you're going to make this much revenue
next year you're going to make that much
revenue the year after that and then
you're going to go public
and we were like what
are you just
completely really
you can do that you could just go public
that's like a thing and he's like yeah
why not
[Laughter]
and that's kind of where it clicked
and that's you know we're like okay
maybe and we started thinking about it
and then
we when we got to the point we were
basically breaking even
which happened you know being talked
about that maybe the year after that we
were already breaking or we're roughly
breaking even i mean it was like it was
not exactly working we're pretty close
to breaking even we're like oh maybe we
should maybe we should consider going
public and the first step if you're
going to go public the first thing you
need is you need a cfo like this
maybe you can go public without a cfo
but uh seems like a really bad idea
don't do that
generally ill-advised
yes so step one is you need a cfo on a
cfo that actually knows how to take you
public
a lot of people give you advice that you
should hire a cfo that has taken a
company public
that is hard for many reasons
for one there's just not very many such
people
secondly
cfos turn out to be very highly paid
individuals
and when you go public you get paid a
lot as a cfo so what ends up happening
is a lot of these people who are cfos
who've taken a company public are just
very rich
and they don't want to work for you
anymore they're just like whatever i
have my house in the hamptons and that's
this is where i am and i'm just not
going to go work with you
so it's just a very limited pool of
people who have taken a company public
once
and so
there's that and then we did interview
some some people and you know they had
good experience what we ended up doing
for cfo is not take somebody who had
taken a company public but you know he
obviously knew finance etc he came from
goldman sachs but we maximized for
kind of
intelligence and grit
and and that was a really good move for
us and so that that worked out for us
quick question so intelligence i can see
how you test for intelligence how do you
assess grit ah it's just you know i i
think a lot of it has to do from
references i mean this one
matt that we hired we we knew a few
people that knew him
and you know every there's a reference
we're just and they were true the thing
is they were truly they'll tell you like
oh matt garupa is like
the hardest working most
and also most honest guy i've ever met
and i'm like to me the words honest and
cfo just kind of don't go together that
much i don't i don't know if i just had
i was biased against that but then we
hired a guy that is like the most honest
guy like we call him
sometimes some of us call him the boy
scout because it's just like this guy is
just kind of a good guy
and so we hired a mat
and you know by the way the other thing
with matt is matt was going to be based
in new york right before covent we hired
matt
i don't know his first day was maybe a
month before covet before like it's
probably like february of 2020 or
something like that he was gonna be
based in new york but we're
headquartered in pittsburgh we have an
office in new york with about 100 people
he was going to be in that office but he
knew he had to travel out to pittsburgh
on his first day he shows up with a
i don't know it had like 10 slides a
deck with his travel plans for the next
two years
he had
pie charts a fraction of time he was
going to spend like in pittsburgh in new
york on the plane like it's all this
stuff that he had done like a massive
analysis like what a consultant would do
for some sort of analysis he's like this
is my travel schedule for the next two
years and i'm like
wow i i would have never done anything
like this but i see we hired the right
person
he must have spent hours and hours on
this and then poor guy kovit came and
then that travel plan went down the
drain and um he just didn't have to
travel
but anyways you hire cfo that's kind of
the first thing and then
and then
for me i think what really
mattered was
is our revenue and this seems to be like
what matters the most is our revenue
predictable is our finances predictable
if your finances are not predictable you
should not go public you're going to
have a real bad time
so you know you want to know that your
finances are predictable and by
predictable i mean
i've learned
you need to be able to predict your
finances with you know a year out
and be like three percent away
so this is a pretty good prediction that
you have to pretty good forecasting so
you have to do that
and you have to have a path to real
profitability that's the other thing
if you don't have either of those i
would say
i i would not go public uh you're just
having a really bad time
the other thing to say about having gone
public i'm very happy we did
the company operates better
i think of it as like you know when
nobody visits you in your house you kind
of don't have to clean all that much
like it's not a very clean house if
nobody ever visits you you're like you
kind of live like a slob it's like but
if there's going to be a visit
coming you're like oh [ __ ] i got to
clean up once a quarter
well it's not once a quarter because now
we're like a constant scrutiny but but
basically i think what happened is once
the process of going public
forced us to do all these things much
better yeah like there were all these
processes that were like they were just
not well set up as a process or like we
may not even have had a process and it's
like no we're going to go public now now
we have to have a process now so at this
point our house is pretty clean because
we get visits all the time
and i think that the thing about living
in a clean house is you feel good about
it yeah you know it's just kind of
better and so i'm very happy that we
went public
you